what someone said i thought was really
funny what someone said this they're
like yo bro you know who i didn't hear
from this entire time in ukraine in this
whole conflict
feminists
yeah that's that's right yeah yeah when
all the women were getting all them
trained with them old [ __ ] right and
the men had to stay behind because you
were between the ages of 18 to 65.
crickets i hear single feminists say
freaking we want to be in equal footing
with the men staying at the front line
i didn't hear a single one break it you
never notice it's always about equal
rights equal representation well [ __ ]
get on the front lines and grab a rifle
oh i got a train ticket to catch i gotta
cook dinner
i gotta be in the kitchen hey baby you
got my apron i got a train to catch come
on
you you go to the wall i just stay here
with the kids yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah guys
guys listen listen i heard they got a
home in poland that needs some cleaning
i'm out this [ __ ]
and look to be fair i'm not saying it's
a bad thing that these ladies gone on
generally speaking i understand if you
speak to a lot of soldiers who actually
do combat roles not support rules
because i'm in the mindset that women
can be in the military it's not an issue
well when it comes to combat roles okay
a lot of dudes and you're not gonna like
this opinion you know like you're for me
i'm just telling the truth i ask most
dudes who do actual combat roles on
deployments they're saying having
females there is generally not a good
thing it's not a good thing
and you guys don't understand if you
don't you guys don't
okay
unders
combat roles are very different than
support roles in the military when you
jump in there's a bunch of things people
who are technicians people who work on
vehicles people who work at supports you
got cooks you got medics you got
everything okay when you work in a
support role the odds of you seeing
combat are like almost zero okay that's
why i always cringe when people are like
thank you for your services like [ __ ]
find out what job they did because they
might not have done [ __ ] all right
people come up to me sometimes thank you
for your service i'm like i didn't do
nothing you didn't get i don't do
nothing no thank you thank you for your
tax dollars stupid i it's not the same
job okay
go i know this because i listen i
respect it okay when i talk to people
who did actual combat roles when i'm
talking [ __ ] who've done like special
forces they understand there's there's
there's levels to it okay i'm that same
token
first
when you're in a front line role
it's a liability okay that whole like
gender representation is a liability
it's not reasonable it's not feasible
okay
so i'm fine with them putting them on
the trains but i think it's also
important for ladies to recognize that
young men are being put to the front
lines to save these territories and to
protect these places and to put their
lives on the line and doesn't just get
higher enough i don't hear people saying
that looks like toxic masculinity do you
hear that never no what is that is that
is that that's a good top good maximum
masculinity yeah that's a good one when
you get the diet the russians are the
evil masculinity the toxic one and then
the ukrainians are the good masculine
the man that's staying the fight or the
good masculinity what about the ones who
are attacking is that toxic masculinity
that's a toxic masculinity okay but if
if you're not if you're replying yes
you're the good kind
you know i mean like if you get to leave
okay yeah and you stay behind like you
leave your man behind right that's not
toxic masculinity okay because you don't
get the fight right i mean because your
man is going to get the fight that's not
toxic though yeah that's not toxic yeah
so like if it's like if i'm in a
relationship with a girl
right and she's talking some [ __ ] yeah
but then the dude wants to talk some
[ __ ] back and get aggressive if i come
into defender he's engaging in toxic
masculinity and i'm not i'm not no
you're not okay because you're defending
her what if the woman stays to fight on
the front line and shoot the russians
with her rpg is she engaging in toxic
masculinity she can't she's a woman okay
woman don't do that i'm peeping it you
know what i mean yeah denying works out
of ten how petty do you think this
conversation is
dogfight
yeah right there's a petty one right
yeah you got a bunch of like white dudes
dying on the front lines of ukraine and
we're like let's take a sting at [ __ ]
[ __ ]
betty
betty buddy but i just i i say this
because it's great to have all these
ideas in a modern society and to say all
this stuff but when [ __ ] hits the fan
you realize how a lot of these gender
norms and gender roles come right back
full circle right all these ideas are
like we gonna do all this stuff we're
gonna do all this stuff it's like but
you're not actually gonna do it when
[ __ ] hits really hits a fan i'm not
saying there aren't women who are
fighting bravely right now who are
helping support and do a lot of this
stuff but i just think it's nice i think
it's funny that
the trains come the wayman leaf
right quick yeah yeah i'm saying quickly
just saying that feminism don't say [ __ ]
though and and for the dudes fighting on
the front line it is a relief for them
because they know their friends their
family are gone so they feel like they
can fight much more safely you know the
people
they know that the people that they care
about are safe so it is an
overwhelmingly good thing but i just
want people to know about this kind of
stuff when they think like oh my god uh
men are so privileged yeah are those
dudes who are stuck there having to
fight in a probably losing battle
privileged
are they
are they i'm just asking the question
are they privileged of course they have
the privilege to fight for their country
yes yes to die for them no it's the
fight for you because they're dying
they're not necessarily gonna die
russia about to [ __ ] them up i listen
it's a privilege to shout out to the
ukrainian people they doing their thing
it's it's it's it's listen it's a
privilege to defend your country yeah
yeah so that's the privilege you got
that privilege you understand what i'm
saying but the thing is the people for
the people what i wanted to say from
since uh before the the people in the
comment if you haven't had military
training or you've been in the mental
military this whole time you were
talking i was shutting the [ __ ] up i was
like speak on because you do not know
the reality of that
let me tell you something okay this is
one of the most egregious things when it
comes to military military's supposed to
be a meritocracy okay
supposed to be all right when you do it
you do entrance exams yeah if you know
what the standards are let me tell you
there's standards for men and their
standards
we're supposed to do the same jobs
apparently supposed to fight the same
enemy but then they have different
physical requirements for women to make
it and to stay in it okay so if men have
to do 30 push-ups women have to do five
okay and let me tell you they're not
even real push-ups no then [ __ ] is
getting on their knees and doing
push-ups like that okay and why do i say
this because i understand there is a
place where having female presence
within the military can be conducive to
a lot of missions i'm not mad at it like
fine i don't care but when it comes to
fighting the enemy the enemy doesn't
care if she could do five or ten
push-ups can she do the job okay and if
she can't compete with a man who did 30
push-ups get her the [ __ ] out the way
get her the [ __ ] out the weight that
means and there's the dumbing down okay
of standards to to appeal to this like
kind of woke stuff but though all this
[ __ ] doesn't matter when when guns
are firing when jobs need to be done
right when you need to carry heavy
equipment and do a rucksack march of 10
10 miles or whatever it is nobody gives
a [ __ ] okay
so it's just important to remember that
we talk about all this representation
this representation guess what a lot of
them can't do the job and they're still
being put into the job and it puts other
people at risk so what you're telling me
is that a man that is doing 28 push-ups
is not going to get the job but a woman
that does five is gonna get it yeah okay
yeah yeah
and honestly when i was going in i was
18 so this is like what 12 years ago
almost 13 years ago
that standard was like that then yeah so
it's been like this for a while yeah
absolutely okay now again if you're
doing a support well i don't give a [ __ ]
because i don't even think it's that
deep right like the support people only
really fight when [ __ ] really hits them
yeah you know what i mean if you got
[ __ ] cooks grabbing rifles that means
you in deep doo doo okay
if you got cooks grabbing rifles y'all
gonna lose okay all right [ __ ]
be handling a spatula shoots his rifle
once a year if he's lucky if you think
he's gonna hit anything you are bugging
if the cook grabs a rifle you're
officially an independence day you're
getting you're getting no you're getting
[ __ ] [ __ ] if your cook is grabbing a
rifle [ __ ] you're cooked okay you guys
are done for you about to be turning to
meet stupid so
i just want you guys to get that
perspective but anyways i i wanted to be
a little bit petty right now with this
whole topic i'm just saying because i've
been hearing feminists just they've been
talking about the military the military
have to be more inclusive and all this
stuff and to be fair i also say this
understand there is a huge issue in the
military with
racism yep with sexism sexism with men
who put their hands on women and force
themselves on women yeah that is a huge
problem in the military and that's a
whole topic for another day i'm not
gonna sit here and just defend
everything but
i just thought this part was fine that's
all
anything you want to say no this video
was not supposed to be long